how to get your logo designed I've got a
great question for one of my YouTube
viewers a loyal YouTube viewer moe Thank
You moe for writing in everyone I need
help designing a logo as well as
specific artwork to be displayed on
t-shirts okay so if you're just getting
started you need a logo for your company
for your brand for your t-shirts
whatever it is I have three main ways
and these are these are ways that I use
to get artwork for my business okay the
first one is there's a website called 99
designs and 99 designs is a
crowdsourcing website where basically
you write in and you say I want a logo
design here's my budget I think logos
start around $200 and people from around
the world will bid on it to create the
logo for you and what I love about this
is you can input whatever design
thoughts you have okay so you if you
want a unicorn in there if you want a
baseball player in there whatever it is
give them some kind of guidance as best
as you can you only pay if you end up
with a winning design so the challenge
of working with typical designers is you
don't know what they're gonna make for
you you've seen what they've done in the
past but you don't know what's gonna
work for you we're with 99 designs
assign designs calm you only pay if you
end up with the final design that you
actually like now I've always looked at
the designs and loved at least one of
them what what happens here in the
process is the designers will submit the
designs you can look at them give
feedback you can say I like that but
make the unicorn Orange you can give
some some tips and they'll fix it once
you have all the entries in you can even
send it out to your friends and say here
are the the submitted ones what do you
think who should win and you pick a
winning design so I love that process
another way that I've hired people is
through website called oDesk and I've
hired a number of people on the O desk
for a lot of different a lot of
different tasks I basically what these
people are are your outsourced team of
workers they love what they're doing
they're
and you have people who are graphic
designers who will want to work on your
projects you put in a bid you put in an
offer and say here's my job it could be
a fixed rate or it could be somebody
ongoing and people will submit and
they'll see you'll see what their
applications are what they've done in
the past and you can hire them on a test
project or hire multiple people why I
like Odette's overnight in our designs
is if you want somebody who will be a
part of your team ongoing so now the
other designs is I want one thing
one-off here it is but if you want
somebody to be part of your team and you
want that same look and feel because
with nine designs each time it's
somebody else
who's gonna be bidding on it so you
won't get that same feel to it right if
you want a design that this has the kind
of same feeling to it each time you make
it or each different t-shirt design
you're doing then you want somebody on
your team so that's where oDesk could be
really great the third option is look to
your network look to your network and
see who you know start telling people
hey I'm looking for somebody to help me
with a logo design and if you start
talking to people and and let them know
what you need they're gonna find ways to
help you you think about companies like
Nike and you think about the swoosh
right that one of the most iconic logos
in the world that was created by a
University of Oregon student for I think
45 bucks something like that and Phil
Knight just went to one of the students
at the University and got it designed
for him so you can look to your own
network of people as well and if they
understand your concept and your passion
and your excitement they might be able
to work with you longer-term beyond just
this one project as well so those are
three options for you moe great question
thank you for writing in
again the summarize one if you need a
one-off design go to 99 designs if you
want to hire somebody remotely on an
ongoing basis potentially look to oDesk
and if you want somebody local who you
can connect with and share your ideas
with who again can be hopefully part of
your team ongoing then look to your
network and start asking people let them
know what you need three steps to get
your logo done believe for those of you
watching this video you like it please
give it a thumbs up below and I'll make
more for you you have a comment you have
a question about your business leave it
below in the comment section
make a video response and if you want to
see more videos like this don't forget
to subscribe to the channel and I'll see
you soon
Cheers